and we're playing tijuna
okay well we're gonna play another
king's indian since i just spent so long
talking about it
we might as well play it
thank you everybody once again for the
tremendous support and all these subs
and
all the hype it's it's awesome
[Music]
okay so this guy plays the main line and
i'm actually going to play a very
interesting line that i myself like to
play that's the movie he takes d4
so in effect we've gotten the marotzi by
instructor from the last game
but there's one key difference i have
the pawn on c7 rather than on e7
what difference does that make well that
gives me a direct line of fire to the e4
pawn
how do i build on that direct line if i
what breakthrough can i prepare
and this is also the main line thank you
yo aguan 21.
what is the sort of typical idea c65
that's the main line season now knight
c6 there is also possible
but the move c6 is the sort of combative
line king h1 he knows the
the best move now what we're supposed to
do here is go
knight out to h5 this should not
surprise anybody who's been paying
attention
to the previous king's indian game
this opens up possibilities like queen
h4
and it opens up one more very important
possibility
he's put his bishop on a square where
it's type one undefended
we have a rook on e8 that's x-raying it
how could we combine the two bring those
together f5
bingo we want to drive this pawn into f4
that creates a stronghold
for the knight on g3 and i'll explain
how to
use that assuming he doesn't go crazy
here
okay so he's prevented f4
he me we ask ourselves straight away the
sam shankland question
what happens if we do it anyway can we
play f4 anyway
yes or no no says mrsupio
we can because if he takes it then we
take and then he takes
he drops his knight on t4 now the
typical move is to centralize our bishop
on
e5 it's a nice central outpost and there
is a particular sacrifice here
that we are beginning to eye and we
actually can apply it immediately
what am i talking about this is a very
very typical
idea in this position it's not d5
anymore he's clamped down on that
it is the move knight to g3 check after
the game i will unpack this properly
so it may seem that we should take the
rook on f1
but here's the thing guys and i'm going
to blow your mind
um taking the rook is what i would do
against another grandmaster
but we are going to go for checkmate
ladies and gentlemen and i'm going to
try to apply
okay well he's actually going to prevent
it sort of
hmm let me think
yeah so bishop d4 was a really really
good move
and i will explain everything after the
game but let us take the exchange so
that we don't forfeit this opportunity
now we've won the exchange and we need
to abide by the key principle
that i always talk about which is that
when you've won material the number one
cause
of disaster after winning material is to
forget
to continue applying basic principles
such as continuing your development
so let's not forget to continue our the
best move here for him would be c5
but he helps us out by trading pieces
get cementing our pawn structure
all we need to do here to consolidate
our advantage is to develop the knight
bring the rook to d8 can we do that here
or do we need to defend the pawn can we
do both
what should black do here
take a moment to tell me the best move
in this position
knight d7 anyway exactly and we can
always smoke this queen out by playing
queen to e7 in fact that's what we're
going to do on the next move
yeah we're up in exchange he goes queen
c7 he's going hunting for our pawns
um that's actually a very good move and
here's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna go queen to d8 wait a minute
daniel you're blundering the pawn
no oh he takes the queen thank you what
would i have done
against queen b7 i was planning to trade
queens with queen b6
okay now those of you who are paying
very careful attention
well what should we do where should we
put this knight
those of you paying attention to the
previous king's indian game should now
know
that nothing happened to this idea we're
threatening a check on d2 which would
win the night
and how can we cement the knight who
would like to remind me
okay well he's i don't think he's aware
that he's down in exchange
we're going to put the other rook on d8
we can always play a5
to prevent him from chasing our night
away in fact that is what we are going
to do just because it's an end game
doesn't mean that the typical middle
game ideas don't apply let's not forget
now to bring our king into the picture
if he goes a3 how do we promote and now
let's begin to attack the king side same
we're playing this as if it's a middle
game because the same ideas apply
uh other than bringing our king into the
game which
uh so because the same ideas apply how
do we proceed on the king's side what do
we do
look at this position it's like a
textbook king's indian position
that c6 pawn protecting d5
absolutely we should push the pawn now
this does a couple things it breaks
through
we have a pathway should we want it for
the king to get all the way to g3 that
would be sort of the like
russian school of but but instead we'll
go g3 but aren't you locking up the
position
isn't that good for white actually no i
want you guys to pay very careful
attention to the g2 pawn
some of you i know are tempted by this
move it doesn't work
let's find a more methodical way to to
apply pressure on that pawn what should
we do
how how do we maneuver one of our pieces
which has already done its job on its
current location
and that's another key thing this is
flexibility of thinking
oftentimes people get like almost
emotionally attached
to like the placement of one particular
piece but you gotta understand that it's
done its job
and now we always remember to look at
the undefended pieces
the knight on c2 is undefended we also
pay attention to the x-rays
and as you guys beautiful job guys
bishop h3
textbook style idea forcing the pawn out
then we're going to take the knight and
promote our pawn or force him to give up
his bishop for it
the game is over yep you guys are uh
very very sharp at this ungodly hour
and uh i love to see it so
that just ends the game
okay well here we just take on g2
and okay knight you one doesn't actually
attack anything so we can just take
and um now the knight is lost boom
over we're gonna send our knight forward
and check madam or promote our pawn one
of many ways and he resigns
very nice game and uh
sort of clearly showed the king's indian
ideas now king h1
is a good prophylactic move right
because he's getting his king out from
potential ideas like this
the best move here for white is to go g4
and this is theory
this sends the knight back to f6 which
is what i had planned to do right at
weakens the king's side but
white has this crazy night at five night
sacrifice
which um which gel fund actually
developed a couple years ago and this
has thrown very serious doubts thank you
see don
for five bucks this has thrown very
serious doubts on
the sort of objective value of this line
there's a lot of analysis here
but by and large uh galfond won a very
nice game here and
uh to that to this date this line hasn't
really recovered
but this is kind of what i'm saying
right
just because it's not viable at a grand
master level doesn't mean you shouldn't
play it
and i want to make that very clear so f5
very typical idea and
to show you guys um
what i had planned to do so knight g3
check actually is simple
if he takes we take and we created a
direct avenue to his king so this is
like the most classical mate in history
now um to show you guys
why i didn't take the rook what is the
ultimate purpose of queen h4 i want to
show you guys a game
against a very strong player and let's
see if i can pull this off quickly
because it was played only chess
and um i need to actually find this game
and download it into chess space so let
me see
and this was against yon kristoff duda
that's why i really wanted to find this
game
because it was against jan christophe
duda
in my match against him naruto vs the
world duda
july 2020. here we go so
guess which line it was this line
king h1 so i played knight a6 in this
game
um which is sort of a rare line that i
that i experimented on and duda believe
it or not
he missed exactly the same idea that we
applied in this game in fact this game
was almost
identical to the game we just played
f5 same thing queen d2
can we play f4 yes we can same thing
bishop e5
literally the same moves rook fd1
knight g3 anyway it's not a fork anymore
but it doesn't matter if he takes we
take it's the same concepts
king age king g1 queen h4 rook ab1
rook f8 now could somebody tell me
what is the idea of this move and this
is exactly what i was trying to do
during uh during
my game but my opponent kind of put an
end to it
what are we doing why do we put the rook
on f6
yeah rook f6 b5 g5
and b takes a6 he simply failed
to see the idea well he played bishop f1
thinking that he prevents rook h6 due to
age three but
no what do we do boom and he resigned
and he simply forgot to check the other
order
because this is checkmate so again
always always always two move line check
the move order
what if you do the second thing first
even if it's a queen sacrifice you have
to do that
and that one's the game so that's where
this all came from i've had
other games like this but because this
was against duda
i wanted to show this sort of
specifically
okay so bishop d4 here i decided to take
now why does this not work because he's
got the f2 square this entire operation
wouldn't have worked because the king
has the evacuation square
so bishop e6 he does all of our bidding
for us knight d7
just the only thing i'll point out here
if he takes b7 i can go rook b8 takes b2
that probably would have been even
better but my original inclination
was to use that technique i mentioned
right giving up a pawn
strategically to trade queens maybe not
the best but really the simplest
um and i mentioned that you have to be
careful about that so we just deployed
the knight we stopped before
and then we just attacked the the king
said everything here i explained during
the game i think everybody understands
bishop h3 is the traditional
sort of classical idea breaking through
and
the game is over and we are white
against roy christian 224 let's go with
an e4
yeah we'll free the plebs after the game
okay so let's continue playing the c3
sicilian i've sort of stuck to this as
my main opening against the sicilian
and and he actually goes here so we have
a fundamental choice here we can go for
an advanced french
uh we can go for an advanced french but
i think it's more thematic
to actually take on d5 because this is
more in the spirit of the c3 sicilian
now we should develop our knight this is
following the famous game hesneridski
and knight f6 deviates from that game
so how should we think about this
position well
i have a choice of capturing on c5 and
that leads to a structure called the iqp
isolated queen pawn
and as i've repeated many times in the
iqp there's a couple of important things
the first
is to to defend the square in front of
the pawn
and we kind of have that under control
but the other thing is trades are
usually good
for the side that defends against the
iqp so here we're going to develop our
bishop with tempo
and we're going to continue developing
with castle what we're doing is we're
waiting for him to move his bishop out
and only when he moves his bishop out
do we do what we save a lot of time in
fact we make
make him waste time what do we do only
after he moves his bishop
which he just did what is it finally
time for us to now do
now we take the pawn so that we force
this bishop to move twice in fact
he doesn't take what can we now do
there's actually several ways to
preserve the extra pawn what's the most
sort of thematic way
and because we have most of our pieces
developed we shouldn't be afraid of a
move like a5 right because
we have our pieces developed we don't
actually need to do anything we don't
need to play a3
we can simply proceed with our
development we can grab the d4 square
but we sort of have that square under
control so what i'm going to do is
actually go bishop to b2 and it
this move may look kind of weird to some
of you guys because the bishop looks
lame
i will explain it after well i don't
actually need to explain it as you can
see that was the whole idea
had we basically are preparing for him
to take whoa
uh okay okay so he just
gives up a piece great uh all right
well uh there's nothing we can do about
that so let's actually develop our
knight to d2 in order not to block
the bishop's control over the long
diagonal knight b to d2
okay now this may look like we blundered
right he skewers the bishops
and we don't need to panic by taking on
f6 how can we protect this bishop in the
most robust way
there are several ways to do it we can
go a4 that's what we're gonna do we
could have also gone queen b3 but i
appreciate that people are following the
rule
of defending pieces with pawns now let's
let's throw in h3 to make some luft for
the king
and now i'm actually quite annoyed at
the fact that we're pinned let's unpin
ourselves by playing queen b3 now we can
we don't have to worry about this
because the bishop is so robustly
defended that there's no way that he can
exploit this uh standoff in fact
we are the only ones who could exploit
okay knight e4 he's trying to stir up
chaos which is
exactly what you should do when you're
down a lot of material
now what does this move specifically
accomplish well he's piling up on the f2
square with three different pieces
so we should absolutely take the knight
queen takes d5 was a little bit more
complicated there and where should
we put this knight who can tell me in
the spirit of playing actively
where should we plant this knight what
is a nice central square where the
knight is
safely protected absolutely where is the
knight threatening to go 92 would be a
little bit
passive and and this is actually quite
an important moment
a lot of people get in trouble because
they play passively when they're up
material
now we're threatening to go to d7 as you
guys see but not anymore he stops it
because then he takes on d7 our queen is
unprotected very important to recognize
that
so what should we do in a situation like
this well our default should always be
to bring pieces into the game and
but our secondary default should be to
ask ourselves what he wants
he wants to plant a rook on d2 you guys
see that
if we put a rook on d1 you guys are all
forgetting the fact that the bishop
is on h5 but because we're up a piece
right we don't need to bring the rook in
immediately there's no urgency in doing
that so what do we do here who can give
me a move
there is one particular sexy move that
i'm thinking of and that is the move
queen swings over to g3 and i'm gonna
play it a little bit fast
because um we're we're a little short of
time
what am i doing as you guys can probably
see i am x-raying the g7 pawn
i'm inviting his bishop back let's
well we don't actually need to take the
bishop but what move is now possible
previously was impossible but how is the
position changed ah
he's moved the bishop back not knight d7
but rook 81 97 and there are some
tactical details here too
to talk about knight d7 there was a
tactical mistake
inherent in that move so we're just
going to take the pawn
and between h2 and h1 king h2 would
potentially bring the king and the queen
to the same diagonal
i don't like the tactical ramifications
of that so i'm gonna play king h1 in
case he takes on e3
you see taking care of your future soft
now does that mean that he literally
would have put a bishop on f4 probably
not
but why risk it you see what i'm saying
now we're completely winning we have
all of our pieces and finally we are
threatening knight to d7
depending on what he does i don't really
even see a good way for him to stop it
he
gives up this rook uh but i actually
prefer to keep the bishop on the board
it's such a strong piece
that let's actually take the other rook
not only is it going to youtube but
those of you who are kind of not
following
um you know i prepared you for this
we're at a relatively high rating
so i'll explain everything in great
detail after the game
uh and again prepare with your questions
i'm
here to answer questions i'm not
frustrated at them
okay who can propose for me
a approach to winning the game
um let's play this by the book queen d6
is great
buy the book activate your pieces okay
queen to d6 what are we threatening
specifically
well bishop c5 that's a good move he
drops his bishop back
where can we put our queen
how can we put our queen let's put it on
e5 let's induce a weakness
let's obviously i don't think i'm under
no illusions that he's going to blunt or
check me that's not the point
the point is that i'm inducing a
weakness and now i'm gonna i'm gonna do
something quite beautiful
we're gonna give him a check okay guys
and now we have a beautiful win
who can find it here's what i'm seeing
his king is
out of squares which means that if we
can rip apart this diagonal
this will be checkmate boom goes the
dynamite rook takes f6
and that is a theme which i saw most
famously in one of harry nelson
pillsbury's games
19th century american master he had a
very famous game
that ended in very very similar fashion
i'll see if i can find it after the game
and uh he sacrificed the queen similarly
now here
we can do a bunch of different things um
but we need to be careful and and one of
them is if we take on e8 and go rook
fade remember that that square is
protected if we go right cafe takes with
a bishop
but what we can do is play rook takes g6
what am i doing the same idea as ror
cafe this is a discovered attack on the
pawn
the only difference is uh we're not
inviting his bishop to go to f8 i'll
i'll spell all this out after the game
and actually the pillsbury game
i don't really need to track it down
it's a classic game where there was a
very similar concept
uh it's not anything to write home about
and that is a pretty sex nomination to
end the game
thank you thank you for agreeing with me
that this is in fact quite sexy
no the snipers are the snipers are real
i mean 18 seconds is enough because it's
made in two at the most
let's see if he can allow us to
sacrifice our queen if he goes bishop f8
we can take on g7 with the queen and
it's checkmate and he resigns
nice game okay let's analyze
so to be clear in the opening we can
play the movie five
and if you know that your opponent
doesn't play the french and you do play
the advanced french
this would be a sensible move because
you would be in territory that is
familiar to you
your opponent would be an unfamiliar
territory i don't happen to play the
events french
and i don't know this guy maybe he does
play the french so i decided to keep the
spirit of the elephant thank you very
cabbage
now he we take he takes we develop our
knight against robert i played the move
c4
um you can find in the vods my analysis
if that came two more subs now
69 and a tizzle thank you let's go uh
let's release the plebs let's release
the print plebs
um all right
thank you guys appreciate the subs
welcome
okay you guys are now welcome to ask
questions
so here he goes knight f6 that's the
main line and actually i think knight
bd7
is quite inaccurate uh knight bd7 is
quite inaccurate
but let's please focus back on the game
okay
okay so knight bd7 is inaccurate why
because he blocks the development of his
own bishop if he goes bishop d7 that's
the theoretical move i would have taken
and then i would have castled and you
get a position like this
where you know i think white has a
minuscule edge
uh and who can tell me why that is when
you're looking at this position
and black is an isolated queen's pawn
what critical factor do you have to look
for in any iqp position what specific
thing uh dictates oftentimes who's in
charge
yes exactly so who has control of the
square in front of the pawn here clearly
the answer is white
i'm basically in charge of that square
but black is very solid i'm not really
attacking the pawn itself
so if white does have an edge it's very
very minuscule
so anyways he goes knight p7 we castle
first we get him to move his bishop and
only then do we take d takes c5
forcing him to waste time taking with
the bishop he decides to give that pawn
up entirely
here we would have given a check and
isolated queen's pawn and here we could
have stopped him from castling with
queenie two among other things
and uh this is a very nasty situation
for black
because he has a very hard time
completing his development that's how
bad these things can get
okay so he castles we defend a5 should
be two this is moment number one
uh those of you who are around for my
explanation of potential energy
should yeah pawn c6 would have been good
should have um
oh knight takes e5 was impossible the
night with spin should kind of
understand this move what i'm doing is
i'm
gearing up i'm a niche gearing up
for a takes before i'm anticipating that
this will happen
okay and when this happens and it did my
bishop
is tremendously strong it's on the long
diagonal
now you might ask well what if it
doesn't happen well if it doesn't happen
then the bishop is still okay
uh like i always say you don't need
every one of your pieces to
to be scaling mount everest at any given
moment we're also just connecting our
rooks and getting our piece out
and um i didn't see a particularly good
other score for the bishop i guess we
could have put it on f4 but one thing i
was
kind of worried about is uh leaving this
diagonal
unattended and i was a little bit
worried about a scenario
where he gets let's say a bishop to f6
you guys can see right how that could be
a little bit nasty
so i decided to prophylactically put my
own bishop on b2 even if he doesn't take
on before
i'm discouraging him from trying to get
something on the long diagonal
all right that's it's more of a
prophylactic move he takes and he plays
a very weird move knight takes c5
if he tried to undermine my pawn chain i
would have of course played c6 that's
kind of the point
black isn't in huge trouble here down
the pawn and i've got an amazing
position
now the rest is quite simple a4
defending the bishop
and let's fast forward to the cool part
a lot of people here
have a tendency to go backward knight d2
very passive and this allows e3 um
and and that's kind of a nasty move so
knight takes the queen takes d5 would
have been
i think inferior because it would have
allowed a lot of complications
uh related to bishop takes that to check
i'm sure that white is still winning
probably i can skirt around these checks
but why allow
all of these complications particularly
since we're up a piece
uh and and you don't want to take that
too far sometimes you have to allow
complications
but uh there are other times when you
can make a judgment call and decide that
oops sorry
there are other times when you can make
a judgment call and decide that um
you don't need this okay you need to
consider the alternative so knight takes
c4 is what i did just to keep things
simple
95 centralizing the night and now
knight d7 why is this wrong because the
rook takes d7
and i can't take because the queen is
undefined but how would you see that
you would see that because i've already
reminded people to always check for
undefended pieces particularly
standoffs this is a queen standoff
and standoffs are you know hot beds of
tactics
particularly when one of the pieces is
is undefended
um okay and so that's how we would kind
of note this down
so therefore we moved our queen away
from the standoff i didn't want it and
while we're doing it we create more
pressure on the g7 pawn
he drops his bishop back we don't need
to take the bishop our knight is very
very strong here we don't need to rush
to trade
now we go rook 81 e3 is no longer
dangerous because he's got no pieces to
follow this up with
and why not knight t7 in this position
guess what we moved our queen away the
bishop on b2 is still undefended and we
still have to
have to note that down he plays rook
takes d7 and he gets two pieces for a
rook
which is we're still better but we're
only up in exchange now no need for that
therefore we go rook 81 in order to
prepare this move and bring our rook to
an open
file okay now knight d7 finally
take the rook uh queen d6 screen back to
e5 attacking
g7 check and now the key concept
why didn't i take the bishop on e3
because it was protected by the the
queen on a7
it was basically protecting that square
uh and here i noticed that the king is
out of squares you actually that's
something a lot of people don't
i think do is detect situations where
the king simply has no squares i know
that sounds very obvious
but you need to categorize that scenario
in your mind
because in that scenario if you open up
more diagonals and files it's very
likely that there's going to be some
sort of checkmating ideas
that's exactly what we kind of thought
of here
king has no squares to escape so that if
we can open up this diagonal it's going
to be checkmate
and the most obvious way of opening the
diagonal is simply to crash through on
f6 takes
takes and bishop takes f6 doesn't queen
takes f6 lead to the same mate actually
yeah so queen f6 is working but it's
actually not that simple because
what you should be afraid of and what
you should not assume
is that he has to recapture here he
doesn't have to recapture the rook
whereas if you start by this move he's
basically compelled to capture the queen
because you're also threatening
checkmate
however if we take with the queen what
should white do in this position
instead of taking the rock this speaks
to the concept of tactical flexibility
always paying attention
uh to the other tactical ideas and
position not just tunnel visioning check
bishop f8 and now using the x-ray
to deliver checkline that one's the game
so he will he goes for k8 and now rook
fade is very tempting i thought of this
initially
but it doesn't work because bishop takes
that fate and the bishop simultaneously
defends the pawn on g7 um and
hopefully that makes sense but but the
idea is correct right
we need to expose the queen's attack on
g7 that's fine
uh that is fine but we need to find the
best way to do that and
the key observation is that the rook
can't move away from the e file he's not
actually really threatening to take our
queen
he actually is because the e8 square is
covered but by taking on g6 we chop the
legs off
from that and so this is going to be
checkmate okay so we use logical
thinking in this way we don't jump to
conclusions
we don't make the move that kind of
looks right we we specifically
okay let's take care of that thank you
uh we specifically um
you know look for stuff thank you
look for stuff rather than trying to ah
this is what would be in a tactics book
kind of stuff okay
any questions any questions
okay noe thank you for the pram
was knight c7 a decent alternative to 95
um i'm not sure which move you're
referring to because knight
c7 was this square
why are we taking the bishop instead of
rook on e8
um well we didn't also not sure what's
referred to but
bishop takes e8 i didn't want to give
away this bishop
i i didn't want to give away this very
very important bishop on me too i wanted
to take the better rook
of course this is completely winning but
i wanted to be precise as precise as
possible
all right guys um we can ignore stuff
like that
okay um
back to the how do you save your games
well they're auto saved
when was his bishop on h why couldn't
you play bishop e2
well bishop b2 where
well bishop b2 was was unnecessary right
and it would also drop this bishop
how do you know which pieces to keep in
which well that's what i'm trying to
illustrate
through the lens of the speedrun why did
his bishop have to leave h5 because we
were x-raying the pawn
if he makes a random move we can move
our knight away attack his queen
and simultaneously threaten checkmate he
can defend both with queen g6 but now he
ends up dropping his bishop or his rook
so that was basically why he went bishop
g6 probably not the best move
but he's already basically busting
uh yeah you can play knight c4 but uh
why why move the knight away from its
most active post
you know why help him uh beef up the
kingside security
so there's really no need no need for
that move i know it's tempting to attack
his queen
but ask yourself is that piece uh
in the resulting position going to be
worth moving there in the first place
and the answer here is kind of no
i'm gonna end the stream for five
seconds and then i will restart okay so
i'm about to end my stream
for five seconds and i will restart it
okay disconnecting in three
two
[Music]
you